donc je suis candidat ici à nantes 6
pour deux et des principales la première
c'est de voir les élections comme une
opportunité de faire la politique
autrement
on constate depuis longtemps maintenant
qui a réellement de la problématique
d'abstention enfin qu'il ya un écart
important entre les citoyens les
électeurs et la politique telle qu'on
peut l'entendre il faut réellement
revenir maintenant c'est ça aussi
l'esprit démocrate c22 d'élever la
conscience de chacun essaie de se
réapproprier ce sujet la sacem est un
des axes du programme avec une méthode
assez simple pour pourvoir ces aspects
là le deuxième axe pour ma partie c'est
aussi de se dire que l'emploi c'est pas
le département lui même qui valent
crémer le département peut en être un
réel facilitateur donc il faut pouvoir
permettre la création le développement
des entreprises de manière simple et le
département doivent être là pour
faciliter cette démarche là ce que je
souhaite réellement c'est qu'il n'ya
plus demain de personnes porteurs de
projets qui ne sache pas à qui
s'adresser aujourd'hui il ya des tas
d'acteurs spécialisés chacun dans leur
dans leur domaine les chambres de
commerce chambre de métiers et autres
l'on sait parfois forcément à qui
s'adresser je pense que créer une agence
de des entreprises passent donc une
agence départementale pour être un bon
moyen de s'assurer que quelqu'un sache
toujours à quelle porte frapper pour
avoir la bonne réponse est qu'il puisse
être accompagné ensuite
donc c'est encore une fois c'est un
esprit humaniste mais de faire attention
à avoir d un département qui peut agir
mais qui peut agir durablement
donc ça veut dire faire attention aux
finances et s'assurer que tout ça
fonctionne réellement